how's it going everybody yesterday was a
very sad day we had to say goodbye to
Captain America so in this video I'm
going to talk about the wrapping up of
the reshoots for Avengers 4 and what
this means if you are new to my channel
I am currently doing a giveaway giving
away a few copies of Avengers infinity
war on blu-ray or ant-man on the wasp
your choice some limited edition posters
and some special edition memorabilia all
you have to do to enter is subscribe to
my channel like the video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so when the Avengers
for reshoots were announced it actually
came to light that they hadn't actually
finished the ending of the movie they
shot Avengers infinity war and Avengers
for it back-to-back and when they
started the Russo brothers actually did
not know what the ending was going to be
so they scheduled these reshoots and
Chris Evans has just finished all of his
reshoots for Captain America when he
finished his reshoots yesterday he sent
out a tweet that said officially wrapped
on Avengers 4 it was an emotional day to
say the least
playing this role over the last eight
years has been an honour to everyone in
front of the camera behind the camera
and in the audience thank you for those
memories eternally grateful Chris Evans
seems to make it pretty clear by this
tweet that he is not going to be
continuing with his role of Captain
America he's played Captain for eight
years he's done an amazing job and his
contract is up and he chose not to renew
it now a lot of people are really
reading into this and saying that he's
going to die in Avengers 4 this does not
mean he's going to die in Avengers 4
there are many ways he could come back
and have a cameo as Captain America
along with all the other characters that
are hanging up the towel as well I
personally think that these characters
that are moving on from their roles and
passing the mantles down to other people
will come back in some way whether it's
a small little Stan Lee cameo like we
always get or if they come back and sort
of provide mentorship to the new heroes
that are in I personally think that
we're going to see them at some point
maybe not all of them but some of them
however every supposed plot leak that we
have seen so far with a vendor's 4 has
stated that Captain America
does in fact die but those are just
supposed plot leaks and when you have
time travel involved with a movie
everybody could technically die and come
back which is actually what I'm assuming
will happen I'm sure that Captain
America or Iron Man or somebody that's
pretty important will die and they will
bring him back at the end of the movie
it's just a nice way to kind of in the
role of a character you have them
sacrifice themselves give their life for
their team you paid tribute you remember
them and then at the end you bring them
back and let them have their happy
ending which i think is what we would
all like for Captain America so Chris
Evans is officially done with his
reshoots for Captain America and
Avengers for clearly an emotional day
for him he said it himself and clearly
an emotional day for Orion rales Ryan
Reynolds replied to Chris Evans his
tweet and true Ryan Reynolds fashion by
saying I'm not crying I'm weeping
there's a difference it is a very sad
day many had to say goodbye to Chris
Evans and Captain America for the very
last time
and pretty soon next year we are going
to have to as well but that is it for
the update on Chris Evans finishing his
reshoots for Captain America and
Avengers for let me know how you feel
about this and let me know if you think
Captain America is going to die live or
die and come back and Avengers 4 don't
forget to subscribe like and comment
below so you can enter my giveaway and
stay up to date with everything marvel
and Avengers 4 thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]